No, the world does not come to an end. The world is just going to Coachella.
*Intro*
and I'm trying to be part of society.
Hey guys, my name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know.
Welcome to my after-school special [laughs]
This is my gang sign.
Music festival season is upon us.
This is when all the clearance sh*t from Halloween gets a huge...
second chance. [laughs]
I've been to a music festival or two in my day-
Literally only two. I've been to two music festivals.
So I know what I'm talking about. Two is enough.
People have two kids and they talk like they know how to have all kids.
They do. Who am I to judge?
So I've created a list of seven Coachella essentials, but these work for any music festival
that you're going to, because Spoiler Alert:
[whispers] They're all exactly the same.
Guitar! Unique, quirky.
Let's get into it. The first thing you need are cute sunglasses!
These are essential because most music festivals, if not all music festivals, take place outside
so you need to protect your eyes against the sun.
I recommend getting a cheap pair of sunglasses
because it's super easy to lose them at music festivals
and cheaper sunglasses are easier to break apart and turn into a
series of shivs that you can use as weapons to protect yourself.
Next on the list is sunscreen.
You're going to be in extreme direct sunlight,
so you want to protect your skin.
Also, sunscreen is slightly edible if you find yourself in a situation in which you need to eat it to survive...
...And there's lots of varieties. They all taste the same:
like sh*t.
Next: cute and comfortable closed-toed shoes.
Yes, you might want to wear those really cute, but really uncomfortable
open-toed gladiator sandals,
but the walk to the main music fairgrounds
is a lot longer and dustier than you realize.
The walk is also a lot longer and dustier than you realize
when the earth as you know it has been destroyed, and you have no actual home
and you're just trying to find a safe place.
How far away that'll be, you don't know.
So invest in some cute closed-toed shoes or lightweight boots.
They'll also help you protect your toenails so that you can eventually use them as currency if need be.
Next - A cute backpack!
You wanna make sure that you have a bag that's big enough for all the things that you might need throughout the day:
your 'stabby' sunglasses,
extra pair of closed-toed shoes to protect your toenail currency...
...Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, the list goes on.
Also backpacks are great because
they keep your hands free
so you can dance as much as you want to,
and you can also fight for your life if you need to.
Next - a bandana.
Music festivals are so much dustier than you think,
especially Coachella.
So bandanas can protect you from the dust, can protect your neck from the sun,
and align you with the appropriate gang when your only key to survival is choosing the right side.
And the last thing you'll need for Coachella or any music festival is: a fake tan!
I use the 'St. Tropez self-tan Express'.
I love it. It doesn't streak. It's easy to apply. It doesn't get all over everything.
It's wonderful to give you a natural tan, a natural glow.
The color also blends into dirt like, perfectly.
So if you need to like strip down naked and lay face down in the dirt
as a means to camouflage yourself so that you're not murdered,
this is the perfect product for you.
So there you go, there are my seven essentials that every person needs
for Coachella or any music festival. I hope these were helpful.
Let me know which is your favorite, or which else I should have included in this list,
and I'll see you guys at Coachella!
Sike, I won't be there.
At all. Whatsoever.
I don't know.
Also, I have been watching a lot of The Walking Dead,
and it is very likely that I got Coachella confused with The Walking Dead,
but I don't see much of a difference: a lot of dust-covered people
doing this
and just all sort of looking at each other like,
"Should we just
kill ourselves? Do we really have to be here?"
[laughs] I'm kidding...
The Walking Dead looks like a much better time!